[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored i'm
still jeremy carl and first tonight a
road riddle how do you get to use the
highways with no license no insurance
without paying any tax and with
absolutely no speed limit the answer is
of course as easy as riding a bike
that's mibelle i promise you one thing
this is the only time ever you'll see me
doing this i get irrationally angry
about cyclists i mean it we wrote this
don't come near me i'm a psychopath
but seriously nice what's not to loathe
there's the toy hoys they dress up like
the tour de france from 15 minute pedal
to work he got the chain gangs usually
four of them riding side by side like
some massive peloton was us tax paying
motorist q behind getting later and
later and more irate you've got the
sigourney weavers uh through the miss
swerving like a shopping trolley with a
dodgy wheel and you're jeremy vines
whoever he is with more cameras than
kodak picking fights and running red
lights it's good news though it turns
out i'm not the only one who thinks
these two tired tyrants are run out of
road today the government announced
thank god it might just force cyclists
to buy insurance follow speed limits pay
fines for ignoring the laws of our road
so at last says me with one hand off the
wheel a common sense reform bringing
cycling into the 21st century oh no so
the cyclist reckless regulation we'll
end up with more people in their cars
we're going to debate that in a minute
but first my friends as i run out of
breath and look at why cyclists think
i've got this wrong i'm getting off now
you see i've got carpal tunnel syndrome
watch this
[Music]
hey
what
are you doing man
too busy doing that mate six points is
that 1.5 liters overtaken
so you've been cool bye-bye now
brilliant right nick freeman the
transport lawyer so good he's known as
mr loophole joins me now uh plus
britain's most militant cyclist dave
sherry uh let's start with you nick um
you have been urging the government to
do this for absolute ages it is chaos
out there i know cyclists won't like
what i'm going to say right but really
isn't it time there was a degree of
responsibility
served on the cycling community nick
freeman
yeah absolutely right jeremy um that
they've avoided it for a long time
although it's the small minority
actually really against it but they're
very vociferous um the many cyclists
have approached me and said nick we
actually agree with what you say because
it's going to make our roads safer safer
and you know their priority is to cycle
safely um but there are what are called
the lycra outs who are really against in
any case i think the day has now come
it's not far away when the government
are going to listen and they're going to
actually impose the same legislation
that exists for cars and for e-scooters
motorbikes motorcycles for cyclists and
um
it needs to happen it's a sensible thing
and i think we'll all benefit from it
and i think it will actually help remove
the friction that exists between the two
sets of the main groups the motorists
and the cyclists it's an unpleasant
experience and um you know on the
continent that there's a much more
friendly atmosphere here it doesn't work
very well and i think this is a step to
making us all realize we share limited
road space we need to be collaborative
we work together and try and be safe for
everybody so cyclists have got a new
highway code which they welcome it gives
them a massive priority but also they're
going to have to comply with some
legislation they're going to have to be
identifiable and i think if they're
identifiable they'll cycle sensibly and
they'll be more responsible because
they're going to be accountable aren't
they well i've got to say one thing
you'll absolutely know in the next 10
minutes why i won't make a lawyer
welcome to the studio dave sherry um
you're described as britain's most hated
and militant cyclist uh and you're sat
there in a in a stab proof vest and
you've got a camera on your helmet davey
let's just start as we mean to go on
right you you've got 10 minutes to
convince me that i'm wrong and and you
are right as a cyclist you tell my team
you have a duty of care under the law as
everyone is using the roads together
yeah yeah if you're using the same roads
as motorists then why don't you have to
pay for it like motorists have to do
them because we're down the mid and the
mission
so that's the only reason you should pay
road tax what about what about the tax
to make sure the roads are are safe and
well kept why shouldn't cyclists pay for
that as well as motorists right low tax
was abolished was brought in as a visual
vehicle exercise duty yeah
basically it's based on co2 emissions
cycles do not do that
cycles i don't think damage too much
tarmac
um
so basically you use the roads and you
want potholes fixed so motor is supposed
to pay for that as well right yeah but
so do all riders mobility scooters oh
come on man listen listen
right cyclists let's let's get let's get
straight to it right the laws for
cyclists were brought in in 1861 for
horses and carts here's what i want to
say to you and tell me i'm wrong right
so there i am in my car and nine times
out of ten and i'm not saying it's all
of them in their lycra with their beards
they go uh
up inside you onto the pavement through
a red light there must be an
acknowledgement in the cycling
fraternity that there are a number of
cyclists thousands of them out to make
motorist lives difficult you must accept
that why have you got a camera on your
helmet why are you wearing a stab pro
fest man
because i don't like the
pre madonna drivers the ones who like to
use handheld devices
the ones who get a bit too close to
vulnerable road users and i understand
what you're saying about the law the
road traffic act is there for motorised
vehicles
cyclists are not motorized vehicles okay
but if you kill someone a cyclist goes
down for a maximum of two years under
the 1861 law i'm not condoning anything
like that if it's a if it's a motorist
he goes to prison for life you can take
your co2 emissions i want to ask you
something why are a majority maybe
majority is the wrong word why do so
many cyclists in my life why are they
out to cause trouble why why have you
why have you got a camera it seems that
it's gone the other way i'm all for
cyclists right if it's fair and proper
but it's not like that anymore motorists
in this country whether you like this or
not are hacked off with cyclists because
they feel like we're second-class
citizens why aren't you insured
because we're not on my wireless vehicle
it's just ridiculous i'm sorry but you
need insurance for a mike ryan's vehicle
what about you someone what about
insurance today and it comes down to a
civil claim civil loss got all the
answers haven't you
you don't i i don't understand why all
right give me another one right so uh if
i'm out on a sunday packs of them right
and i have to move out five why are they
allowed to cycle in pairs why not in a
straight line circles for road users and
entitled to use as much of the lane as
they deem fit so you can use as much of
the road as you want because your road
users but you don't pay for the upkeep
of that because you don't have co2
emissions is that right where do you
think that's there right where does it
say we have to pay for it or contribute
to it
what i'm saying is in terms of if you
look at it cyclists seem to be gaining
the upper hand
is that a good thing or a bad thing bad
thing for whom what for who the rest of
the world
pedestrians are not upset about it i
don't believe horse riders
no
531 incidents i believe off the top of
my head last year with cyclist uh
hitting or bashing into pedestrians and
how many vehicles is that your answer
i'm asking do you not think that
cyclists should have a series of rules
to to to give them responsibility be
that tax or you do it's called the
highway code for cyclists do you not
think you should get points if you cause
problems on on on a cycle do you know
traffic act cyclists are not accountable
is that it the road traffic act can i
bring in nick nick come on these laws in
1861 for horses and cats come on man
give me a bit here it's outdated rubbish
isn't it well
you know
dave's known for being a vigilante
cyclist and he goes around with this
camera and that's obviously his
privilege to trap motorists who are
actually breaking the law many motorists
have dash cam footage yeah and what they
have is a picture of a cyclist going on
the pavement knocking someone down going
through red lights they have nothing
more than that because they don't
they're not able to identify the cyclist
so you know dave wants it all his way he
wants to be able to identify the
motorists but not be identified himself
so that's the first thing that's wrong
the second thing is he talks about
insurance and says well there's a civil
claim many cyclists don't um don't have
money so if they seriously injure and
you said 531 were seriously injured last
year it was actually a lot more than
that this is the tip of the iceberg many
aren't actually reported because the
cyclist leaves
how is the injured party going to be
recompensed by somebody who doesn't have
insurance answer that dave i wouldn't
say answer the person who's injured with
it answer that now let's let nick finish
no answer the question under everyone's
car motoring policy you've got a thing
called uninsured losses and this is for
other formalities that transpire on the
road would that be agreeable nick
no it wouldn't dave because i'm talking
now about when a cyclist hits a bit and
injures a pedestrian yeah and this is a
serious case that's happening more and
more frequently and cyclists are
uninsured so there's no remedy for the
cyclist that's of that for the
pedestrian and that's of course um
dependent upon the cyclist being
apprehended stopping at the scene many
of them don't
do you think the law is biased and
sometimes
at the end of the day the podesta
well the pedestrians you know he's
injured he's lying they might have a
broken leg whatever loses his job etc
etc no recompense because we haven't got
a responsible cyclist who can hold his
hands up he's got money in his pocket
and he has no insurance so there's a
huge disadvantage and that's why of
course motorists have to be insured so
it is going to happen cyclists are going
to have to be insured along with these
scooter riders and of course electric
bike riders which is something that's
going to come out it needs to happen as
far as contribution to roads are
concerned of course there are no
emissions
but there is a cost to the the taxpayer
to the public of having cycle lanes for
for allowing them to do what they do
and there's no such thing as a free
cycle there must be some level of
contribution um and it's blind to simply
say you know we don't cause any damage
to the road surface we don't harm the uh
environment so why should we contribute
well the answer is the the motorist is
having his his space surrendered to the
cyclist and that's something that he's
contributed to financially and there
must be a price for the cyclist to pay
for that completely agree with sharing
limited space it doesn't it doesn't come
free thanks nick what's your answer to
that dave sherry i agree with nick on
that in principle but then my argument
in return would be
are the horseriders
you should be a politician are the horse
riders home to use there aren't
it's not about horse riders it's about
but look here's what i'm going to say
you go out with your camera and your
stab vest you're looking for trouble
you're a vigilante you love all this
stuff i'm simply saying to you we
motorists feel like it's all stacked in
your favor we pay all the bills we take
all the rubbish we've got all the fines
we got and it's about time cyclists who
seem to increasingly dominate our damn
roads took a bit of responsibility
what's wrong with that man
car drivers over the years have had that
same mentality the shoes on the other
foot because too many cyclists were
being killed due to negligent driving
and basically this highway code changed
changed the mentality
what's so important to you why are you
why do you why are you so pro cycling
did you fail your driving testers i mean
no i'm a professional driver you're a
professional driver
and you've taken this and what so do you
literally feel like you have to wear a
stab proof so bad are my fellow
motorists is that right
sometimes motorists misbehave and so do
cyclists
no one's perfect
but it's that well that's a would you
rate it again you should be in the
conservative government man you haven't
answered a question do you think that
cyclists should take more responsibility
final question for
road upkeep for insurance do you think
they should be regulated yes or no you
do yes yeah if it makes a road to save a
better place there we go every road user
so you agree with me
to a degree if it makes things improve
yes it would be forward and just get rid
of that camera thank you very much dave
sherry thank you and cheshire nick
freeman mr loophole